well authorities in western germany are
rushing to clear mountains of debris and
restore
vital services after devastating floods
last week
many areas were left without access to
drinking water after the flood waters
damaged waste
water treatment plants and concerns are
now mounting over an environmental and
public health catastrophe
as sewage flows into rivers more rain is
forecast
complicating the cleanup
a main road into the flood hit area
covered in tons of rubble
most of it washed onto the road by the
floods and the rest dumped there by
clean-up workers
there's nowhere else to put it
towns are still surrounded by debris
and plagued by an overpowering stink
rivers are carrying rubbish and sewage
and the heat of summer is fueling fear
of disease
this is a sewage work serving one
flood-hit area
surrounded by a lake of filthy water
the works itself has been severely
damaged
it's unclear to the local authorities
when and if
it can be brought online again
until it can the waste water is left to
flow
right through it
at the moment we're working as fast as
we can to come up with a provisional
solution
the fact that the water is getting into
the river untreated
is an environmental catastrophe
the soil is contaminated with oil so of
course
there's been environmental damage but
our main priority is restoring the
infrastructure
for the people who live here
the regional government has set up an
emergency aid program to restore
wastewater plants
sewers and drinking water as fast as
possible
but at the moment it's still impossible
to estimate the total damage
one of the affected towns has already
received an emergency drinking water
system
but now the technicians have to move it
again
the weather forecast predicts rain for
this coming weekend
so the tanks are being moved to flat
ground higher up the workers
expect they'll be here for months
the new location has a lot of advantages
we've reactivated a well
so the quality of drinking water we were
supplying will be even better
and we can put the whole system indoors
more than a week after the floods hit
the river here is polluted
and washing the debris down towards the
rhine
well social media has played a key role
in connecting people affected by the
flooding with volunteers who want to
offer support
dw reporter tessa valtter visited one
town where a group of syrian refugees
answered
the call for help
with every shovel the piles of mud are
getting a little smaller
but after the enormous floods in west
germany there's still a lot left to do
here in zinter a group of young men is
helping the people worst affected by the
disaster
they came to germany as syrian refugees
six years ago
germany has given us a lot we've been
welcomed here
now we want to give something back
we want to help the people germans
foreigners
anyone hand in hand we are working
together
we're doing as much as we can
the young men answered the call on
social media
they've come from all over the country
and are paying their
travel expenses out of their own pockets
some are even using vacation days to be
here
anas al-akkad put out the call for
volunteers online
together with two friends he had a
simple but very clever idea
we collected pieces of information that
were already circulating on social media
in german
then we translated them so that arabic
speaking people could understand
once the information was out everybody
wanted to help
them ana's created a group online
hundreds have been signing up every day
i was very surprised when the numbers
started to go up
so quickly by now i'm a hundred percent
sure
that it could go up to a thousand
and when i imagine this place here with
thousands of people helping out
all together in an organized group that
really
gives me goosebumps
that kind of help is desperately needed
here
these home owners like many people in
the region
have lost almost everything
in these dire times the support given by
the young
man is highly appreciated
these guys really sacrificed themselves
for us africans syrians everybody
they worked all day for them it went
without saying
they've really helped a lot
[Applause]
with each day a little progress is made
for the volunteers there's still a lot
left to do
let's get the latest on the story now we
have our correspondent benjamin alvarez
gruber he is in availa one of the most
affected towns on the ground there for
us hi benjamin
how are people coping with these
challenges that we just heard about like
water supply and cleanup efforts
they're coping with these challenges
with the help of several organizations
that are here on the ground so we have
volunteers
for example installing mobile showers
and we also have the german red cross
that have installed
a clean water facility that you can see
behind me more than 26 have been
installed here
in this region more than a thousand
liters there's a lot of trucks
carrying this water around all day so
there's a big problem with water
and not just with drinking water there
are some people here in avala who got
water already but this is service water
and authorities are calling on people to
boil this water as
maybe also chemicals inside of this
water so people can just come here with
buckets with
bottles to fill up and to have some
water also
not just for the residents but also for
the volunteers so the german red cross
also wants to entitle mobile showers
as water and hygiene is a very delicate
topic for the authorities here as well
meanwhile authorities are also
scrambling benjamin to find people a lot
of people are still missing so
how was the search for them going
the search continues rescue teams think
that they might continue
finding bodies as they still are pumping
water out of houses and of underground
parking lots
many of them don't think that they will
be still able to find survivors only
here there more than 155
missing there is the german army the
bundesver soldiers
police officers and firefighters who are
working around the clock to still try to
assess and
still try to reach houses so the
volunteers are also playing a very
important role here
we've seen a lot of groups of volunteers
have made it
to this place their shuttles also with
buses to prevent also
problems with traffic is ambulances and
firefighters need to get quickly
to the scene so there are a lot of
people working here on the ground the
search continues but
unfortunately the hope to find survivors
is it
continues to decrease in addition to all
of these challenges
more rain is forecast for this coming
weekend
how will that affect the search and
cleanup efforts
that's right the german meteorological
service is expecting heavy rains on
saturday and sunday there are several
groups preparing in case
more evacuations are needed and
several organizations are asking for
more help to see how this
where these people could live there are
already several emergency shelters here
but of course they might need to
evacuate
even more people so they try to find a
solution
ahead of the work the rescue work that
of course if the rain is too strong on
saturday and sunday will not be able
to continue with that so authorities are
preparing for the worse even though the
numbers and the focus says
that it will not be as heavy as the rain
floods
that we saw last week our correspondent
benjamin alvarez gruber in availa
thank you for that update